We have a voicemail number.
That number is wo ne ine wo.
David P. this is the funniest set of voicemails.
There's this very, very angry Trumpist named
Jimmy from Philly.
And he calls in every once in a while, but
we haven't heard from him for months.
And um, every once in a while he will email
me and complain that he was not notified about
a live stream I was doing on YouTube or he
was not notified about a live stream I was
doing on Twitch or something.
And it's like, dude, these are just your settings.
I don't know what is going on.
I don't know how tech savvy you are.
He sent me wo voicemails.
I've been streaming on witch dot TV.
Some of you may know this and he sent me wo
consecutive voicemails, furious about different
elements of the Twitch platform.
Take a listen to this.
Debbie, Jimmy from Philly, number ne, I like
to thank you for lions to me about Twitch
being free for Amazon prime members.
Yeah, it's free for hirty days.
No, that's it.
So listen, the prime membership does not automatically
renew, but every hirty days you can just sign
up again.
If you have Amazon prime, you can subscribe
to witch dot TV slash David Pacman with Twitch
prime for free for hirty days, and then when
the hirty days are up, you just subscribe
again for free.
There's no, you don't have to at any point
switch to a paid subscription if you don't
want to.
I think that's an important little fact that
you left out.
You're wrong.
And Twitch is such a piece of that at least.
Or the mobile phone.
I mean, it was such a pain in the ass to set
it up and day and then to try to actually
like post a message.
I mean, are you kidding me?
It was just, Oh my God, I to ive minutes.
I just, I mean, I'm like, no wonder y'all.
We have ive hundred people at Twitch, David
[inaudible], which sucks.
Who's paying welve ninety nine a month per
twitched at it.
I don't even know what Jimmy's talking about.
So I, we, I think there's actually the potential
for a show here called tech time with Jimmy
from Philly.
Uh, here he is continuing his, his tirade
about Twitch.
Yeah.
With Jimmy from Kelly.
I'm so pissed off.
This Twitch app.
Are you out of your mind?
Do you know how hard it is to use a mobile
phone on this?
I mean, it's insane.
It's literally insane for inety nine a month
that,
yeah.
Okay.
So anyway, there's Jimmy from Philly and extraordinarily
angry, extraordinarily furious.
But seriously, folks, Twitch works great.
The streams have been great.
We take phone calls.
I will sometimes play games of chess against
people in the audience.
I sometimes get crushed, but sometimes I win
a, the Twitch streams are actually really
great.
So follow me there.
witch dot TV slash David Pakman.
If you do have Amazon prime, don't listen
to Jimmy.
It's free for as long as you want it to be
free hirty days at a time a on the bonus show
today we will talk about if you are stressed
out by politics and I know more and more people
in my audience are, I will have some tips
for how to continue being engaged in politics,
but without losing your cool.
We will also talk about here in assachusetts
there has been a our month ban on all vaping
products, which is the toughest action that
any state has taken so far.
And uh, I want to talk about that as well
as I have a lot of friends in assachusetts
in sort of tangentially in the vaping world,
either in the cannabis industry or in different
industries that are related.
Uh, my Facebook feed has been just blowing
up with this stuff.
And lastly, the house has passed a bill that
would allow banks to work with cannabis companies.
This has been a big impediment actually to
when we talk about legalization of cannabis.
You don't want to be working in a cash situation
if you are ne of these cannabis dispensaries
or whatever else because it makes you a target
for a burglary.
It's just you want to be accepting credit
cards.
You want to be putting money in the bank and
that has been something that has been limited
for banks to work with cannabis related businesses
and the house has passed the bill.
We will see what happens in the Senate that
would make that much easier.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, I welcome you to the bonus show with
open arms.
You can get access instantly by signing p
at join PackMan dot com and or by becoming
a patron at Patrion dot com slash David Pakman
show.
Look forward to hearing from you there and
make sure if you have any thoughts on today's
program or anything else, any message you
want to send me, you can use the voicemail
line wenty four hours a day
at wo ne ine wo David P, I'll speak to you
on the bonus show or on tomorrow's program,
the David Pakman how at David Pakman dot com.